[Music]  it's definitely not a life of luxury for  Gordon Ramsay's for children what am I  like at home I'm an absolute nightmare  that's true in a new interview with The  Telegraph Ramsey reveals that life in  the spotlight does not mean free  handouts for his kids vote they don't  sit with us in first class they haven't  worked anywhere near hard enough to  afford that at that age at that size  you're telling me they need to sit in  first class no they do not were really  strict on that I remember you Kevin Hart  publications three daughters and the boy  oh my goodness and get this the famed  chef has no intention of leaving behind  his reported 175 million dollar fortune  to his kids quote it's definitely not  going to them and that's not in a mean  way it's to not spoil them  [Music]